[Music]
this is a demonstration of how to be
more creative with less but more
specifically how I achieve high budget
Hollywood shots like this this and this
do using objects from around my house
[Music]
[Music]
and being my own stuntman taking it back
taking it way back when you start out in
any industry access to the best tech the
best gear the most experienced partners
is just a pipe dream so you really have
to do with what you have to be able to
stand out to make a statement
my first two young film director Awards
are when it can where one from films
that had absolutely no budget through
improvising it actually made these films
a lot better more roars more personal
sometimes access to the best can
actually be more limiting I have to keep
reminding myself to scale back and
that's why this week's idea really
started this is exactly why I loved
YouTube I grew up watching movies they
spoke to me in a way in which nothing
else did I couldn't get enough of them
so eventually I became a film director
so that I could make my own movies and
YouTube is an added bonus of creative
expression over and above the
traditional stuff it's a platform for
experimentation so I just want to say
thank you for watching for commenting
and keeping this YouTube channel alive
okay when I click this experiment off of
only using objects at my disposal or
around my house and whatnot with a wild
card entry now I don't even know if this
one is real or not but it is insane
Czechia
this DP must develop as a ninja on the
weekends I think I have a little bit
more of an attainable idea for this but
I'm guessing now that I'm gonna have to
be the one in crashes into the car as
well the idea for the shot is to amplify
the sensation of impact by having the
vehicle moving forwards well I come
along in a skateboard and as I hit the
front the car slams on brakes I roll
over and the camera makes its way
through the window and to the other side
this is a simple wheel from a road a
door I just took it off from the inside
of the house attached to it is string
with the 360 gophers it's gonna make its
way through the window
[Music]
okay so the idea is I would be going
forwards
I'll stop what hit it pull over man man
and the cameras gonna check that whole
movement
[Music]
[Music]
okay next up is mr. robot check the shot
out
[Music]
actually have the behind-the-scenes shot
other two
Thomas mail has such a great vision with
the show and it's just so cinematic it
makes it really really enjoyable to
watch I obviously don't have a great
triangular-shaped staircase or a motion
control rig worth hundreds of thousands
of dollars but what I do have is a fire
escape rope and some other bits in order
to recreate the shot so the idea here is
that I upcycle this wheel that I stole
from my shower door for the previous
shot and I'm using it as kind of a puddi
to move our way down the stairs I'm just
simply gonna drop it
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
whoa okay next David Fincher's Fight
Club I absolutely love this film
probably one of my all-time favorites
you see how the chief warps there you
will have to recreate that in town
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
in order to reach David Fincher's real
explosion at the end of the fire club
scene with a gun we're gonna recreate
that with this leaf blower this ideally
is the tip of a gun it's gonna hook in
there and when I apply to my mouth it
will create that warp and that kind of
explosion that you really want to see in
slow motion okay I'm gonna open that
shot up in After Effects I'm gonna
remove the background add a few elements
[Music]
there you have it and lastly the love
stranger things in entering the
upside-down the camera rotates like this
now what you may be thinking is but Dan
you can just track backwards and post
rotate oh no because the shots is moving
in a full 360 degree angle would have to
zoom so far in and actually crop out all
the quality and this was shooting 12 K
which we don't have the shopping cart
and my super 73 bike along with the
GoPro will have to do the trick
[Music]
[Music]
very simply I just added this platy I
connected a whole head with a GoPro
which is nice and stabilized and a wheel
from the bicycle creates this resistance
so that it can really be nice and smooth
and what's very important is that the
lens is just near Santa so that with the
circular motion it doesn't swing from
side to side and you can kind of keep
your object it's a it's a then we use
the shopping cart to move us back and
forth and what's great about the GoPro
is the stabilization so that you know
the bumps on the shopping cart had
already counted that very nice if you
were doing a shoot for a client
I wouldn't rock up with this thing okay
it looks like [ __ ] taste one for the 360
stabilized rotation stabilized a 360
rotation circular rotation break
[Music]
[Music]
I hope if anything I taught you some fun
and interesting movements yeah I know
for a fact that I learned that I am
definitely not a stunt man my back hurts
oh by the way thank you so much for all
the comments on my last video where I
made the track
Godzilla by Eminem out of my
girlfriend's hair ties okay a bunch of
comments telling me to get a job or
asking where I get all the free time and
believe it or not this is my job thanks
to the brands that supports us creators
I'm able to make videos every week and
experiment and just make rad [ __ ] and
talking about incredibly supportive
brands that I use every single time I
make a phone story blocks video the
sponsor of this week's video story
blocks is that ultimate time-saver and
stress reliever there's been so many
times that I've written a shot list and
I just don't have the time to go out and
shoot all of it so I go over to story
blocks and see what I can use there for
my video and just really shave time off
that shooting schedule so head over to
the link in the description and check
story blots out and get unlimited
downloads to their member library to try
out any clip you want in your next
project in HD as well as 4k there's also
After Effects tablets motion backgrounds
and much more all the content is
royalty-free so you can use it in your
YouTube videos without getting a
copyright claim they go over to the link
in the description and check them out
then lastly subscribe to my channel it's
a simple click of the button if you have
already I appreciate you so much so so
so much and turn on that notification
bar so that you don't miss an upload
like the next seeing sounds where I'm
gonna be making a soundtrack using only
basketballs other than that
don't forget your awesome brew and I'll
see you next week
[Music]